what's going on guys this is rob and i
recently realized there's a story where
thanos meets
kang and it's kind of a cool thing right
so we covered the story of infinity
conflict a little while ago and this is
basically the prelude to that so those
of you guys who read or who saw our
videos on infinity conflict
you guys kind of know how this turns out
but it is a little bit of a cool thing
here right so this initially picks up
with thanos just kind of re-experiencing
we're kind of going through all the
various victories he's experienced over
the years and even defeats his
experience over the years
while he's in the realm of mistress
death now for those of you guys who
don't know
when it comes to the to the realm of
mistress death and marvel comics we've
talked about this so those of you guys
who are familiar with this just bear
with me for a second while i run over
this for the new folks um
originally death didn't work this way in
marvel comics instead if you go back and
you look at the old
stanley jack kirby stories right tales
of asgard all you really had was the
realm of hella and that was basically it
it wasn't until the old iron man stories
and the introduction
of mistress death and thanos that you
basically learned there is a definitive
afterlife for anybody who doesn't follow
like the asgardian mythos basically and
so following that basically the role of
mistress death is where people go when
they all just
more or less die right earthlings things
like that and then places like the realm
of mephisto or the realm of hella the
realm of satanish different things like
that
are all kind of special circumstances
for people who barter certain deals or
different things along those lines but
for the longest time
thanos was always rebuked by mistress
death and a lot of you guys probably
know that that he had a kind of love
interest in the form of the fact that he
was always pursuing the affections of
mistress death and she was always
shooting him down
and so that was kind of the cornerstone
of him nihilism things like that and
there was actually a point in marvel
comics when he was banned from the realm
of mistress death now that's where the
infinity line of stories
sort of differentiate from the main
marvel universe and the reason why is
because the infinity gauntlet was a
landmark story was huge when it first
dropped and
of course gemstone followed up with that
with the infinity war and the infinity
crusade but the infinity line of comics
proved to be so popular that marvel just
gave him the ability
to write his own stories and so
following the events of infinity crusade
those stories
largely became out of continuity right
so they don't necessarily tie
into the main marvel universe and so
you'll see events unfold but they're all
just kind of alternate reality stories
for example
in the aftermath of jonathan hickman's
avengers and new avengers secret wars
the death of the living tribunal in the
infinity stories adam warlock in an
alternate reality became the new living
tribunal now that was incontinuity in
mammal comics only because the living
tribunal is a multiversal
being so if somebody in an alternate
reality replaces him it's basically the
new living tribunal
across the entirety of the multiverse
including the main marvel universe but
outside of that
everything else is basically out of
continuity and so with thanos kind of
reliving all these experiences and
coming to this realization that he
really seems to have
everything he wants that he's still not
content and so he kind of goes on this
quest to really kind of goes on a bit of
a journey to figure out what it is that
leads him to
lack being content with his current
environment and so you switch over to
eros now those are guys who are not
familiar with comics eros is basically
the brother of
thanos that he also goes by the name
star fox and his ability is to kind of
you know emit pheromones and basically
get people to do almost anything he
wants
especially to kind of fall in love with
him or to see him as desirable that's
why you initially see him in bed with
just like five
chicks because that's kind of the thing
of eros he usually uses his powers in
order to get girls
is is really what it is but in the midst
of him just kind of musing to himself
and sort of you know walking around and
so on and so forth he's basically kind
of whisked away
through a a kind of time portal and then
on the other side
a new portal opens and you're met with
king the conqueror and a
and basically an unfamiliar individual
now following that as far as eros goes
he's kind of whisked away to uh
basically a different point in time on a
prehistoric world and he's really just
kind of trying to escape
as best he can and get away from things
but for thanos himself
basically he's met by corvus glaive one
of the uh the coal obsidian and he's
essentially told that a kind of temporal
disruption
has emerged on titan and that's
interesting enough for thanos to
investigate right at the very least it's
hey look i can go do something now to
kind of fulfill this lack of contentment
that i have and essentially find out
what's going on here right and so
when he emerges on the scene he's
basically met by this
kind of uh individual who is who's kind
of disappeared
and kane the conqueror who is basically
left and so with this cloaked individual
he basically reveals himself to be
what is in effect a future version of
eros right and so time travel
of course is being invoked here now one
of the funny things that goes on
is that with kane the conqueror when he
had emerged he was trying to stay away
from thanos and the reason why is
because thanos is one of these
characters in marvel
where he's not easily killed more so
than that if thanos
comes across you and realizes you're not
supposed to be there or that you could
offer
some measure of him to achieve a goal
he's been setting out to achieve he'll
take you right he'll conscript you or
he'll kill you or something along those
lines but one of the things to know is
that thanos is
well beyond the power of kang the
conqueror and so there's not a whole lot
kane could do
and facing off against thanos not only
that because thanos is so wildly
intelligent say for example that kang
were to appear at a previous point in
time
then thanos would likely deduce that
kang had appeared to him at a future
point in time
realized he couldn't defeat him and so
he came back to a previous point to try
to destroy him and end up destroying
kang right so it's one of those things
where thanos intelligence is
such a high level that he can kind of
figure things out
pretty quickly and so what you end up
finding out is that when this future
version of eros kind of starts telling a
story
about why it is that he looks so old and
you know what was going on with him in
the future and so on and so forth he
reveals that one it's been 2
000 years since he and thanos saw each
other and that two
he was basically in a kind of exile for
2000 years you know in a in
on basically what was uh this kind of
world called zeltya and that when he
came here when he stumbled across this
world that he came across a primitive
race that tried to destroy him and for
the most part it was only because of the
fact that on this world
there's only three different races and
anybody who doesn't match that race they
kind of see him as basically an edible
animal right in the same way that we
would see like a deer
or something like that is something that
we can hunt and kill and so ultimately
eros is saved by one of the other races
here
and the reason why they saved him is
they realize he had a ship right so he's
not necessarily of that world and so in
turn they were like you know
you can probably help us at the very
least help us to you know to kind of win
this conflict because
these three races are always at war with
each other and so as this bit of a story
kind of goes on
you end up finding out that this version
of of eros had basically helped this
race to achieve
uh i guess a higher state of
enlightenment with regards to weapons
technology
being able to like evacuate their world
using ships and things like that so
basically ushered in
a kind of technological golden age for
this particular race
right and in doing that kind of gave
them the tools they needed to evolve
beyond the stars to travel beyond the
stars that's incredibly important here
and the reason why is because
what you also end up finding out around
that time is that king the conqueror as
he was going through
his you know timeline and really the
history of the universe itself and
always trying to expand his empire
came to the realization that at a future
point in time thanos would come across
a basically what he referred to as a
stygian darkness basically kind of like
a mysterious phenomena
that essentially encapsulated a world
traveled beyond that world into the
stars and then eventually fought thanos
and destroyed thanos and so the desire
of kane the conqueror
is to essentially keep that from
happening and the reason why is because
any force out there that's powerful
enough to destroy thanos
especially in this higher state of
godhood that he seemed to have achieved
is a threat to the entirety of the
universe and by extension a threat to
the life of of king the conqueror
because remember
when it comes the way that jim stalin is
writing this which again is kind of out
of continuity here
that if something affects the past it
can affect the future and so looking at
this
the concern of kane the conqueror is
that if a organization or race
uh basically conquered the universe at
that point in time
then it's entirely possible it could
spread outward and because it seems like
it's not supposed to exist
somebody had meddled with time and in
turn caused this whole thing in the
first place and so the desire of kang is
to ensure
that it doesn't spread beyond the stars
and it doesn't spread throughout the
entirety of the time stream and in turn
basically destroy king's empire and even
control kang himself
and so tracing this back to his genesis
point kang believed that it all started
on a planet named zeltya with people
that had the ability to teleport
basically this race that eros had come
across
uh while he was essentially exiled and
the desire of kang
was to basically kill this first
teleporter and then in turn
stop that from happening the problem is
that it didn't work that throughout the
time stream this always kept on
happening that this this
you know stygian darkness this kind of
powerful entity out there
kept showing up again and again and
again and there came a point where kane
got so close to it that it almost
consumed him and so in a panic
he basically sent his ship flying
through the time stream with no
definitive arrival point and he
ultimately stumbled across this barren
world
2000 years into the future which
basically housed eros where he had
basically been defeated and kind of
removed and
exiled to that planet and by the two of
them working together they ultimately
cultivated
a plan that was designed for the purpose
of eros coming back here
and trying to find a way to work with
thanos to stop that stygian darkness
from happening and so the way this plan
the the planet the two of them concoct
is that at the end of the day
the the race on that planet zelchia is
gonna have to go right because of the
fact that it all originates from there
that essentially they're going to put
together at least as far as the plan
that kang and eros had formed that
thanos would assemble what is in effect
a small little contingent team and they
would in turn travel to this world and
they would basically lay waste to all
life on it and that in doing so it
should stop that stygian darkness from
arriving here now as far as the version
of eros goes that had been thrown into
the past
much like the future version of himself
he had kind of given this race weaponry
taught them
technology all kinds of different things
the ability to travel into space
and so the hope here is that in doing
that they would basically present
themselves
as a more intelligent and capable
organism and that the hope is that if
thanos truly dies in the future that
because this race
is gonna basically has their evolution
kind of jump started by eros and
basically giving them advanced
technologies which partially come from
the shia
empire they would be able to help thanos
quell that threat in the future and that
in doing so
thanos is basically not going to destroy
eros he can return to his own timeline
and essentially not be destroyed or kind
of uh
exiled at some future point in time the
problem with all this is that
in both of these scenarios they
basically solidify what's going on with
the stygi and darkness that this
this race gaining interstellar travel by
way of eros
is really what causes all this and the
reason why is because one of the members
of this race who's here
is basically met by the cause of the
stygian darkness right the cause of this
kind of
walking death that exists out there and
this person comes in the form of a being
called
hunger now those of you guys who are
familiar with jim starlin's whole
story with hunger and all that kind of
stuff um
this is one of those concepts where
comic book fans either think it's cool
or they
hate it and for the most part the only
people who really liked it were die hard
jim starlin fans everybody else was like
this is ridiculous
this basically sucks uh the whole thing
behind this is that hunger was basically
an extra dimensional being
that basically latched itself on to to
galactus and it was kind of jim
starlin's way of saying this is why
galactus desires to consume everything
because he's actually possessed by being
called hunger ultimately it was defeated
and largely believed to have been
destroyed the reality
is that it's returned here and the way
this explanation is given to us
is that at some point because of the
fact that hunger came from an
extra-dimensional space
it had kind of been manipulating things
the entire time and that entering into
this realm that it needed a source of
energy to basically achieve this so it
basically
rode the infinity stones into this new
reality bonded itself to galactus and
then in turn
when galactus and thanos fought that
when it was believed that hunger was
destroyed
a small piece of it survived left
galactus and then traveled throughout
the the universe
trying to find a suitable host to bond
itself to and that's when it arrived on
this world
and bonded itself to this this you know
one of these three races and then in
turn
wrote itself into the future and then
ultimately ended up conquering and
destroying thanos right so this
is the actual darkness that everybody or
really that kang and all those guys were
essentially concerned about and so the
other part of this is that what you end
up getting
is thanos who's essentially whisked away
into
what's referred to as elsewhere but it's
really more of a far-flung future and
he's kind of met by this
you know kind of disembodied voice that
basically tells him that what's going to
happen here with regards to everything
taking place with
with eros and all that kind of stuff
then in the end it is all still going to
result in thanos dying no matter what
plan they implement here that hunger is
going to spread throughout the universe
and it is going to kill
thanos and that ultimately hunger will
consume all things
and so in order to keep that from
happening the plan of eros and kang
is not going to work and so another plan
needs to be manufactured here
the problem with this is that if eros
for example is killed it'll basically
lead to a paradox in the time stream and
so what ends up happening is thanos kind
of shows up here on the scene
and basically ends up encountering his
brother eros when he shows up
at this point in the timeline and so
arriving here eros is basically attacked
by thanos who basically you know
seems to more or less kill him and then
just throw him out into the middle of
nowhere and so following that because of
the fact that the only way to basically
keep
that future from happening where the
universe is conquered by by hunger and
everybody is eradicated is for thanos to
wipe out the entirety of this race and
this is appealing to thanos because as
you guys know
thanos loves the concept of death and
thanos loves to destroy
all things that exist and so this
basically leads to thanos kind of
amassing a fleet
based on the new plan that was created
between himself and this
disembodied voice that was talking to
him the person that we don't see
and they basically eradicate everything
here which is the other reason why eros
was basically killed
by thanos and so in the midst of all of
this right like with
these members of these races basically
evacuating based on the ships that were
given to them by eros this whole
plan of thanos and its future version
doesn't necessarily work out the way
that they intend it
and so this conversation between thanos
and his future self basically continues
when you end up finding out that that's
basically revealed to thanos that even
though he was believed to have been
successful even though he thought
he had killed enough members of this
race at the end of the day it doesn't
matter right the true
architect of this whole stygian darkness
will basically arrive and in turn he'll
end up conscripting what's left of this
race across the universe
into his army and that at the end of the
day thanos will still die
and so ultimately the only real way to
stop this is to actually go after that
source itself
and so this leads to thanos eventually
tracking down hunger and then
annihilating hunger right destroying
this this bit of an entity here
now of course hunger tries to possess
thanos and it doesn't necessarily work
out that way instead thanos manages to
destroy hunger
entirely and that basically brings it
into that and so following that you
basically find that because
future eros is alive that means that
eros in the past
was not actually destroyed that instead
it was kind of a paralytic effect that
was
imposed on him by thanos and his body
was just kind of thrown into the lake
and then that was basically it
and that it was really more of a
distraction than anything else all for
the purpose of
solidifying this plan more so than that
you end up having kane the conqueror
that just kind of appears here and then
is met by the arrival of thanos
right and the whole point was that
thanos was meeting with king for this
idea
that that in solidifying the destruction
of this particular
of really hunger itself that now kang is
in the debt of thanos
and so in turn the the question kang has
is then what do we do here and thanos
response is like what are you looking
for
i've destroyed this guy like what all do
you want out of me or what are you
looking to achieve
and the idea is that kang really simply
just wants to rule
a section of the universe for himself
write a section of the multiverse for
himself
and that thanos will leave him that
section right because thanos is destined
to achieve this level of godhood that's
basically what kang says
i know what your future is going to be i
know what you're going to look like i
know the level of power you're going to
achieve and when that time comes
what i ask is that you allow me to rule
my little section here and you basically
leave me alone right because at the end
of the day if that doesn't happen thanos
will end up destroying kang so if
anything
it's really just self-preservation and
so ultimately the response to thanos is
fine i will do that
but you will owe me a debt right like
you owe me a debt here in order for me
to allow you to
to kind of rule your own section and
then in turn the the whole thing here is
thanos basically says like you will
basically travel to the year 4027 and
you'll wait in orbit above chandelard
and then in turn you'll be met with
orders and you'll be told what to do
and so that all that really does is kind
of solidify thanos role here
right the the fact that he is in effect
going to become his future counterpart
now when you switch over to this quote
unquote elsewhere discussion you end up
basically finding out the whole story is
more or less told in hindsight
and all this is done for the purpose of
solidifying
what thanos will become that there does
come a future point in time when thanos
basically becomes the universe itself
now it actually goes beyond that right
when he attains the astral regulator
which again is the whole idea behind
infinity conflict and he basically
imbues himself with everything right he
becomes like he takes over the living
tribunal he contribute he absorbs the
one above all he takes over mistress
death the whole nine yards right like he
becomes what is in effect the entirety
of god
and the whole basis behind this story of
everything that's happened
was done for the purpose of ensuring as
far as that future thanos goes that his
existence
actually is maintained right that
nothing gets in the way and nothing
stops that more so than that
because hunger was seemingly this
universe-wide credible threat and the
only thing that really seemed to be
powerful enough to actually stop
uh astral regulator thanos that this is
now quelled and it's out of the picture
and it's done and so basically there's
no one standing in the way of astro
regulator thanos
becoming this most powerful version of
himself now that story does play out in
the actual infinity conflict and you
guys can check the video down in the
description
nonetheless let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section if
you guys say like yeah rob this story
sucked
i totally understand i don't like it at
all but thank you guys for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace